hello folks welcome to rational science
and today we're going to be talking
about the second but before we get to
the second let's go to first
and we're going to be talking about
a little bit about extinction subjects
related to extinction and we start with
a little uh
note that came out there uh related to
the ukrainian war
now for those of you who are not aware
uh
the there was a ukrainian war until
recently
and
it's over now so if you missed it well
you got to go back in history and find
out what it was all about
yeah the the war in ukraine is over and
it's over because all the fun
has already happened
now it's just a war of attrition now
it's uh just throwing bombs destroying
cities i'm not sure that's going to
change very much
uh maybe they reach an agreement find me
shake hands and uh
you know they all try to come out as if
they won the war that's typical if if
they reach some kind of a truce
but the war is over all the fun is over
all the uh
penalties all the things that they were
gonna do
you know that's already happened right
now i think it's just gonna be the same
old same old everyday
unless which i doubt uh
they start pressing those red buttons
i don't think that's going to happen
um
my guess i'm at my my take um but if
that happens we're all in trouble
then uh extinction will happen a little
sooner than what i thought
but uh no if uh things continue as they
are now um it's just gonna be a war of
attrition and essentially the winner
here is the united states it's the only
country that has won here uh russia has
lost uh already ukraine has lost already
europe
as as a continent has lost already the
only winners china also i think has lost
to some degree okay because
they're going to be applying a little
bit of pressure on the chinese i think
the only country that really comes out
on top here is the united states so it
was a good move very uh sagacious uh
move on the part of the united states
government
whether it's going to have some
long-term consequences
we don't know
you know it's anybody's guess but
anyways here's the uh a little note
little headline that uh happened this
week that caught my eye okay and i want
to comment on this okay uh biden says uh
warns of real food shortage risk over
russia's invasion into ukraine
and he warned on thursday that there
would be global food shortages resulting
from the russian invasion of ukraine and
announced steps to prevent a potential
crisis okay we did talk about food
shortages and it's going to be real the
price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries and our country as
well
biden said
both russia and ukraine for example are
providers of wheat
though he pointed out that the u.s and
canada are also major wheat producers
okay
and president announced his intention to
read double combined efforts with the
european union to increase global food
security provide direct food aid we're
warranted to prevent a crisis in a joint
statement et cetera et cetera right the
president said nato leaders talked about
urging all european countries and
everyone else to end trade restrictions
on limitations on sending food abroad
okay
and
uh us and sally biden said are in the
process of working out how to alleviate
food shortage concerns and rising
inflation and lingering
uh supply chain issues okay
and uh so
why do i raise this issue well as you
know i'm saying that uh the extinction
of man is going to come as a result of
food
and some people might look at this
article or something similar or another
article similar to this and say oh bill
there's your theory
food shortages
okay i wanna that's what i wanna clarify
this is not about my theory at all okay
this has to do with the united states
trying to push russia and ukraine aside
both countries so that it can
supply
the world with more wheat okay this has
to do with business with politics uh not
with my theory my theory is says
something a little different okay it
says that
money will be no more money will
collapse nobody will believe in money
nobody will accept money any kind of
money they won't accept gold they won't
accept uh bitcoin or any crypto coin
they won't accept uh
dollars or euros
nobody will accept money okay because
the global economy has collapsed
because nobody accepts money no one
produces food especially the
corporations that today
produce and distribute food and
therefore food doesn't get to where it
has to go which is to the cities
uh the city starved to death primarily
the cities but
just about everyone who depends on
buying their food
uh you know suddenly there's no food to
buy because there's nothing to buy it
with because nobody will accept whatever
you offer them
that's the theory so when these people
talk about food shortages we're talking
about something else we're talking about
politics we're talking about business
we're talking about um
moving russia out of the picture so that
the united states can take that same
spot same with energy
same with
weapons you know the united states now
compelled
germany to buy or to invest 112 billion
dollars
in
military equipment
defense
and
guess who they're going to buy it from
guess who the seller is going to be
how about wheat same thing who's going
to sell it hey canada and united states
and so on and so forth so
what this war means for the united
states is is a big coup that cou
overall you know on the market uh the
united states is hoping to take the
spot that russia had at least with
europe okay and possibly even with other
countries
so it's not it's got little to do with
my theory my theory is something
different my theory says again that the
economy global economy has to collapse
first okay why will it collapse well a
series of reasons maybe a couple of them
to mention is one population is not
increasing at the rate it has been in
the past it's the global
growth rate global growth rate world
right total population of the world
right the global
growth rate
is steadily coming down
okay and that's that's important
steadily
no longer like what happened in the 14th
century people say well we had a crash
in the 14th century we recovered this is
something totally different
those days population was young
today the population is old
the reason we're not having children the
reason the growth rate is going down is
we're old
and we move to the cities
and there's issues of economics and
culture as well but those would be the
primary ones
and and then the other one is that you
know uh the jobs we're creating are not
jobs
okay when you create a job in the
service industry you're not creating
much of a job but when you create them
within the service industry in the
internet
business
in the internet world uh you're talking
about ads you're talking about
entertainment
that's not work
not at all okay so we're creating that
kind of work which is not work for real
and
again like i said you know if you're
standing up there with god looking at
the world right what do you see well
what you see is what's there what exists
what you see are the railroads you see
the bridges you see the houses
you even see the food being grown in the
fields maybe the cows
what you don't see are the services what
you don't see are the internet services
you don't see entertainment
there's no such thing that you can see
out there called entertainment you just
see someone moving his hands that's all
and you don't see any product from that
just maybe a smile
entertainment what is that so um you
know when you create internet jobs
you're not creating jobs at all so we're
not creating jobs that's the problem
okay and so
that together with the fact that we're
moving from the country to the city
process known as transition we're
becoming urbanites
there's this
global movement global okay every
country
uh is becoming urbanized okay people are
abandoning the farms the lands the big
cracks of lands and those are being
bought out by the few corporations that
mass produce food and deliver them to
the cities so this process is going on
everywhere
and we can't stop it it's because it's
in the self-interest of the corporations
to do it
uh
a lot of the
farmers they have no choice because they
had debt and they can't pay for it so
they sell their land others prefer the
lifestyle in the city especially the
new generations so that transition is
unstoppable there's no way you can
overturn that and go back to the country
now people say well some people go to
the country yeah usually they go to the
villages because they don't like the
hustle and bustle of the city
but it's not like they're going to be
farmers they're going to smaller towns
but they're living just like they lived
in the city instead of living in an
apartment they live in a house that's
all the only difference but it's not
like they're going to the fields to
produce food that's that's why they're
not being subsistence farmers by any
mean by any chance of the imagination
so yeah the theory
of extinction has to do with food but
it's got nothing to do
with
the scarcity of food which is being
produced now and part of it part of that
scarcity has to do with raising prices
i was keeping track here in germany
you know i go to the store and i'm
paying for um
um what is it uh for a couple
items that i buy veggies okay uh and i'm
paying 20 more cents in just a month
and that amounts to
20
of the price that i was paying before
so the prices are going up you have this
inflation going up
and suddenly you know the uh
especially the
salary person the people the
proletariat
you know
all they can do is live off of their
salary and if their salary has less
value at the store
among other places right well you can
see what's what's happening here until
they catch up to the
new prices to the inflation
well it's going to take a while you know
there might be strikes and who knows
what else in between
certainly a lot of the unions are going
to fight their loss of wages their real
loss of wages right
okay anyways moving on here uh fellow
says do governments have to build cities
why not private corporations instead i
mentioned the fact that um you know uh
governments
i like to pick on two of them i'll pick
on three of them before maybe we we have
land in australia we have land in canada
we have land uh for sure in brazil and
argentina these are big countries russia
okay and so you have all this land
that's empty land
and you say well you know i mean we're
just talking about numbers okay we're
not talking about quality here we're
just talking about volume right well we
could fill those lands with more and
more people right
so one of the things we could do is uh
put people in those places create new
cities
and who can do that except government
okay the government would have to
implement some kind of policy or create
some kind of incentive
especially for the youth for the young
people to go out there you know to the
middle of siberia or in argentina to the
middle of patagonia right in the middle
of nowhere and say okay go ahead build a
city
you know the air of colonization is over
governments can't do that they can't
force people to go out there and build
cities so this fellow is saying well how
about corporations what if corporations
somehow create you know city somehow
okay
after all you've got uh something
similar happened to detroit you know
where uh the car industry was installed
there and
people flocked over there because of
jobs and became a big city right so you
know and there are other examples around
the world but the question is uh
california you know gold rush and so on
uh so what kind of gold rush can we
create
and
you want to put government aside go
ahead what
gold rush
can corporations create for people to go
in the middle of siberia
or in the middle of canada up north
there or in the middle of the uh desert
over there in australia and say oh we're
going to found a new city
you know i claim it for the queen of
spain put your flag in there
is that ever going to happen again or
has the era of colonization come and
gone
and i'm saying corporations have no way
of uh incentivizing in creating
incentives
for especially for the young people to
go in the middle of nowhere and create a
city it's the other way around people
are moving from the country
to the cities because they like the
hustle and bustle
it's a place where
the youths at least they they have
opportunities
uh maybe to develop their careers and so
on that's where the universities are et
cetera et cetera all of it is in the
cities
so so
it's the other way around the youth are
leaving the country
you know their parents stay behind but
they say no i'm going to go to the city
and so all the youth are essentially
coming to the city first to study them
to get jobs there
and you know then you get stuck with a
job you're not going to go out into the
country in the middle of nowhere you
know
with your shovel and uh your pig and
start uh creating you know a new a new
uh city a new village
it doesn't happen and i'm not sure what
any corporation can do let alone the
government right uh to
create some kind of interest especially
in the new generations for people to go
out there
quite the country i would say that
people would rather go into apartments
play with their computers
and you know pass the time away
so
i don't think people are interested in
going to the farms in and i'm sure that
if you told
90 of the young people today
anywhere from 15 to 30 at least to go
out into the country and um settle there
i don't think one would go there okay
everybody's abandoning young people
they're they're abandoning the country
so no i i don't know give me give me a
mechanism or some kind of uh
incentive that the companies can give to
lure people into the countries now you
might say uh
i don't know one possibility is a
corporation creates
a uh a plant in the middle of nowhere
well that already is very odd
you know i don't think too many
companies will want to go in the middle
of nowhere with no roads
no way of getting to the cities and just
put a plant there and say okay people
come here and work for us
you know usually corporations look at uh
where they're going to put a plant i
know this uh from working at amd and
they look at places where you have
education
where you have good roads where you have
good tax breaks
and all these things that they take into
consideration before
moving or
putting a new plant you know a new uh
fabrication area or whatever into a new
place into a new city and usually
i'd say 99 of the time if not 100 they
go to cities they don't go to the middle
of nowhere they don't go in the middle
of the desert and say we're going to
install our plant here
no way it not it doesn't happen these
days at least you know maybe in the old
days
days of the cowboys
kansas you know
nebraska yeah could happen not today
okay
yeah is a myopic pedantic pessimist i
resent that
uh
i resent the pessimists in the myopic uh
pedenki i'll
accept believing we run out of
conceptual measure like money leading
into extinction isn't realistic
well again uh like i said the other day
we have to
differentiate
a
pessimist from a realist okay
and that's the first thing we have to
distinguish in other words pessimist is
not a realist the realist is someone who
can explain to you something and say
objectively okay and so that's what i
try to do with extinction a pessimist is
just a guy who that without necessarily
having a reason says oh
the world's coming to an end you know
yeah that could be a pessimist
and again it's different than the
realest who would explain why the world
is coming to an end and again i gave the
example last and one of the examples i
gave a guy falling from an airplane
okay
and we see him you know the door opens
somehow and the guy just fell off right
one of the passengers and so you see him
falling in you say oh that guy's gonna
die
you're such a pessimist bill
no no it's not pessimism you know i
think that's quite realistic to think
that the fellow is going to die right
so yeah i like to distinguish pessimists
from realist i'm saying i'm a realist
uh i give an ex objective um explanation
of why uh humans are coming to an end
and it's got to do also with with the
past uh what i do is look at how did
extinctions happen in the past the ones
that we can certify you know we see
those bones in the mountain
in the middle of the rock right and we
say okay here's a dinosaur further down
what do we see maybe a
um
i don't know
an archosaur
further down you go and you see a
synapsid and further down you get an
amphibian so they're all in the
different layers of rock okay so you say
okay how long did this take well so many
millions of years and so we say well
these animals are not around anymore and
we look at their bones uh try to make an
image of what that animal looked like
and we say well they're these animals
don't exist anymore
so those were extinctions okay and so i
try to explain what happened at each
stage you know and i'm saying mother
nature has only one mechanism for
extinction one and only one and that
mechanism of extinction is food
it's known as economics
people say economics economics has to do
with supply and demand curves and prices
and
and labor and interest rates
that's uh man's particular economics
mother nature's economics is a little
broader okay
and it only only has to do with food
also for humans
okay
we manage all this stuff all the we do
computers we do uh cars we sell cars we
do uh internet we do all this stuff why
do we do it so that we can eat and live
one more day
without eating without that food
we're dead
so we need food all the rest is just
cosmetic or has to do with our
particular uh way of doing business or
economics in our world
you know uh you can't give money to a
chimpanzee because
you gotta look at it and say what is
this what are you giving me no i want
your banana i'm giving you some money
you know i don't think the the monkey
would trade his banana for a little bit
of paper
and you go to the ant hole and ask the
queen and say look
i'd like some of your food that you you
know
accumulated over time and again what do
you offer them bitcoin
gold
so no we don't trade with the animals
because no animal accepts any of our
money of any kind because that's only in
particular to our world
but what do we use what do we use all
that money for to exchange it for food
that's the bottom line
you can do whatever you want but you
can't live without food even bill gates
you know with all his money and all
these other people uh rich people the
queen of england
they need to eat
without eating they're dead
so it doesn't matter how much money they
have if they get stuck on an island
there's no food
they're gonna die and they can have the
entire treasure chest in front of them
and all the uh
things that they own all the stock that
they own all the land that they own it
won't help them one bit what they need
at that moment in time is food
and that's all we have we what we do
every day whether we know it or not
we're trading money for food
that's it and then we live another day
and then the next day we do the same
thing
so
so food is
is the only mechanism that mother nature
uses to create extension mass extinction
by the way not background extinction
and uh
and so when we look at that uh
we say that all extinctions all mass
extinctions happen in exactly the same
way it would it was when food
disappeared
that the animals disappeared okay why
did the food disappear was it because of
some kind of asteroid or maybe volcanic
activity or maybe
you know a
star that exploded nearby a supernova or
something
not the way mother nature works mother
nature doesn't use volcanoes or
supernovas or asteroids to kill species
the way she does it is over time
the plants become old
their population pyramids overturn
they lose their genetic diversity
and they go on their way out while a new
more uh vibrant pla plants in that were
in the background they start covering
the land
and help to displace the old
order
so when the plants are finally gone
and the new plants have taken over the
land
all the animals that depended on that
old source of food
they disappear with the plants that went
away
so plants and animals
die at what is known as a mass
extinction more or less at the same time
that's the theory okay
and again uh it's got very little do
with uh mr biden's politics and uh
uh his uh
threat
to
sell food
to places that were buying it previously
from the russians and ukrainians
okay so
my 10 cent's worth
okay let's move on to the subject matter
today which is the second
okay
and
we have to put in the proper context
okay uh
we're talking about space time here
we're talking about general relativity
we're talking about mathematical physics
and of course uh
time is a very important parameter in
mathematical physics
and in the case of general relativity
you have space time which is like the
foundation of general relativity at
least it's the uh
bread and butter
the uh
you know the the foundations okay and so
you have space and time and time is half
of that
i would say it's even more than that
even though you have three
as they say three dimensions of space
and one of time i think that one of time
is a lot more important than the three
of space for mathematical physics
time is the one that they play with
you know that's the one they put in
equations and move around and
stretch and divide and do all these
little things and we've been doing that
at least since the days of the greek
okay
so um time is the most important
parameter as far as i'm concerned you
know that's the way i see
space time and mathematical physics in
general
time is the key aspect the key parameter
okay so we talked about time the other
day okay and
what was my conclusion uh i ended up
approximately in the
19th century there was really not much
in the 19th century i ended up in the
18th century actually but the point is
that you know until the 18th 19th
century
we had no definition of time no one
could tell you what time is what it
meant what the word meant okay they
could not define the word
and it turns out as we'll find out today
that even to today we don't have a
definition we have no idea what time is
not we but the mathematicians meaning
that everyone who follows them which is
99 plus of humanity also has no idea
what time is okay so we have the
mathematicians we have the blind or the
one-eyed leading the blind you know we
have these guys who don't know what time
is and everybody else who thinks that
they do
that's that's the situation
okay so let's do a little brief recap of
what i covered the other day so that we
put it in the right context and again
it's got to do with space time okay
and this is essentially what i talked
about the other day uh plato greek guy
they call him philosophers i don't think
they were philosophers at all okay
he said that time is not the same thing
as eternity in fact there are exact
opposites
and you say what what do you mean plato
what are you talking about and yeah
eternity he says is the now whatever
small interval you can make that into
that's eternity time on the other hand
is succession of events and so time is
like involved with motion whereas
eternity's uh
involved with existence okay so he
separated time from eternity
and um
and yeah okay uh that was his notion uh
aristotle comes later and he says uh was
a student of his right and he had a
different idea he said look time is
really not motion but quantity of motion
they translate it as number of motion
but to me
number of motion makes no sense i think
he was talking about quantity of motion
and
one of the issues there is that you know
you you you have to have motion of some
kind in order to have time uh you would
think that that's the case
and one of the problems i found also
with plato's uh notion there that
eternity is um
is opposite of time is that eternity is
defined as eternal time
and so you need to define time before
you can talk about eternity so to say
that eternity is the opposite of time
that's like saying black is different
than white but you don't define either
one okay so yeah we need to define what
time is before you can talk about
eternity then you can say that they're
opposites well anyways aristotle said
that
time is quantity of motion okay
and essentially all the other people
that came afterward just repeated what
plato and arie
stottle
came up with
you have these three
religious folk uh saint augustine and
some and thomas aquinas right
and they essentially said the same thing
and the their idea was that god was
outside of time people would ask you
know
how's uh
how is it that god created time like
what happened before then
and so they had to find an answer to
that question they said look god is
outside of time you know god created
time itself god is the god of time okay
and um
but then you know if you ask augustine
you know what is time you say if i have
to explain to someone you know i have no
idea what it is you know he says he
knows what it is but he doesn't he can't
explain what it is he can't tell you he
can't define the word and anselm you
know he he comes up with the block
universe okay again he says god is
outside of time he sees the past and the
present and the future all in one block
so the
block universe that general relativity
gives credit to itself for having come
up with no that that comes all the way
the idea already was um
you know on the books since the days of
anselm
and uh thomas just provided coral areas
to both augustine and some
and there's a couple of them god lives
in the now that stands still
which is more or less what plato said
and god doesn't have to dig into his
memory in other words
god doesn't have to memorize because he
doesn't have to look in his file cabinet
to find out what happened in the past
he sees it all there in front of him uh
past present and future all if it were a
block so he doesn't have to look into
his memory that was his notion but again
you can see these people were just
trying to justify that
god was outside of time because if god
was within time first he wouldn't be so
powerful and second if he created time
it would explain why you know there was
not an infinite amount of time before
god created the universe it's just that
god created time okay so that was the
notion there
newton well he he screwed up completely
he writes in his scolium his famous
principia book uh that he's not gonna
define time because everybody knows what
it is oh great he didn't define time
space or motion because everybody
already knows what it is so why am i
gonna take the trouble
but he had this notion of absolute time
that you know when you die time
continues like there's this time machine
in in the universe that uh rolls time
out
and it doesn't matter what you do
times continues to roll independent of
you okay so that was the notion he had
that was later on gonna be challenged by
relativists okay
uh they talked about relativistic time
and then you have these two guys in the
18th century human kant okay and uh
again you look at then you find that
after so many centuries they had not uh
zeroed in on the definition of time hume
says time is a manner in which some real
objects exist in other words
successively like one object assists
right after another which doesn't tell
us much okay
and kant said uh he
really addressed a lot of hume's issues
and he asked the same question that
aristotle began his
physics book four with and that is is
time and entity is it a thing and does
it exist so he has the same questions he
starts out in the same place where does
he end up well he says time is
successive
you know spaces coexist so he says that
whereas objects can be at the same
place okay i'm sorry in the two
different place at the same time time on
the other hand cannot be at the same
time time is one right after another so
he was saying that's how time differs
from space okay not sure if the uh
relativist will agree with that but uh
he ends up with this definition he says
time is pure form of the senseless
intuition
what the hell does that mean i have no
idea okay but uh again it shows that
these people could not define the word
time they had no clue what it is they
died without understanding the word time
and they just rolled along and today a
lot of people who
call themselves philosophers they study
you know especially human can't and
they never picked up on that the fact
that these two
individuals never were able to define
the word time so there's nothing to
study about kant and hume because they
cannot define time
so what are you going to study them for
study someone who can define the word
time then you'll know something about it
and the same with aristotle and plato i
mean what are you going to go and look
at their books for if you know i mean i
look at them
so i should slap myself but there's
nothing you can learn from them other
than you know how they reasoned to come
up with a no definition
or a definition which is unscientific
irrational because they can't use that
definition consistently
so again you know why study them other
than to know oh it's nice this is what
they thought about time
okay so what's the issue the issue is
that
the unit of time is the second okay we
don't know what time is but the unit is
the second okay
and
a lot of people have this notion that
the second uh
in fact they explain it you'll go
through the internet and look at maybe
90 95 percent of the articles out there
maybe even more
uh and they say that the notion
of the minutes and seconds came all the
way from the submarines uh acadians uh i
don't know the uh
babylonians assyrians you know egyptians
no
those people who say that
haven't done a minimum of research and
certainly they are not very deep
thinkers okay
there was no reason no purpose
to using seconds and minutes
in days of old
you know
and so the question is
what the uh sumerians came up with
was the number 60 the the
system based on the number 60.
you know they were interested in in
numbers like 3 4
12 24 60 though 30 you know those
numbers were important to them and they
built this system based on 60 instead of
on a decimal system or you know the
tens and hundreds okay so
their notion was 60s and what did they
come up with well they have a couple
theories of
how they came up with them and it's got
nothing to do with the second or with a
minute okay so that's that's what i'm
trying to say here okay and here's a
summary of that okay uh here's the
sumerians okay
and originally you know they more or
less figured out that the earth orbits
uh the
sun in about 360 days okay and uh
so you know the earth orbit is equal to
one degree per day okay
they looked at their fingers they said
hey this is a good way of um you know
mnemonics to to be able to uh count and
do quick math
and they said look if we divide the
fingers the four fingers right and we
take the thumb out and you count the uh
phalanges uh well you you know you have
12 of them and so that's a multiple of
three and four and then if you multiply
it by the five fingers of your other
hand where you get 60 and so they
started doing all these calculations
based on this system and that's where
they came up with a 60. and then they
figured out that the you know the
circumference
had 360 degrees what did that have to do
with well
maybe i mean this is my guess but i
think it all is related the fact that
you know the circle if you take the
radius of a circle and
you build uh six uh
equilateral triangles
you can fit them in there
in inside a circle and so you have six
equilateral triangles they each side of
those triangles is the radius and so you
know you can see why they started
playing around with the number 60 and
numbers related to 60. but this has
absolutely nothing to do with the second
or the minute okay
this is what they were using in those
days this this was their clock okay
which was the sundial okay
and you can see uh that
it's built in
units of hours okay you have all these
hours there
and the hours don't go 24 hours you know
they go like from nine in the morning to
six in the afternoon
so it was when the
more or less when the rooster crowed
to when you punch your card out and that
was when you couldn't see anymore out
there in the field and there was no use
in staying out there you know maybe a
lion might pounce on you so you better
get out of there so you know this is
what they were using and it was a
question of hours not a question of
minutes or seconds not by a long shot
okay now later on they uh came up with
the um
with
the klepsidra which was a
a
sand clock but done with water okay in
fact the
water clock preceded the uh
the uh sand clock the hourglass
and what was it is so so they would have
this drop
fall from one uh
bowl to another
and uh you know that
they more or less had an idea how long
it took okay they probably measured it
against the sundial during the day and
they said okay it takes so much water to
fall and this would be approximately
eight hours and that's what they started
using at night
for what i don't know i mean if you're
going to sleep at night why do you need
to know
what happens every hour you know so
i don't know exactly why they would
control time at night or be interested
in that but
apparently they had some use for that
but the issue is it was all hours
it all had to do with hours
the
minutes and seconds
they started really coming into
use
if not theoretically but you know actual
use
in the 16th century in the second half
of the 16th century that's when they
started building some of the clocks some
of the accurate clocks and they started
putting the minutes and the seconds
which by the way you know people say
where are they called minutes why are
they called seconds well the minutes
minute you know small
it was
a piece of the hour
okay what was the second
well it was the second division of the
hour
so the first division was the minutes
the minutes the smalls okay and the
second division of that was the seconds
that's why they're called seconds okay
so you had the second the second
division of the hour okay that's why and
and then they put the second hand okay
in there
and uh one of the uh
fellows that built clocks in those days
was this gentleman here his name was
jose bergie and you can see the clocks
that he made they were very very fine
clocks these clocks are by the way
available today they're in museums
and they're beautiful clocks and uh
obviously
the people who bought these were
princes okay they they they um
in fact contracted bergie to build them
not only burglar were
obviously wasn't the only clock maker in
europe but he probably is one of the
most famous ones because he really built
beautiful clocks and so they
you know the princesses uh contracted
him to build clocks for them and you can
see they're
very fine
built in gold and so on and you know for
that you needed uh someone with money to
pay for that it was a
it was a work of art more than than just
uh
you know a time keeping device but
imagine if the prince had this on his
bed his
uh night uh table you know it has this
little device that measures time
accurately to the second and it was
quite accurate because apparently it
only fell back like one second per day
for for that time for the 16th century i
think that was very very good okay so
they were able to
calibrate it to to that level
and yeah the princess must have been
very happy with with that little device
and of course there are a few clocks in
general from those days because you know
it was a very expensive device that only
rich people could afford i mean if you
were poor you probably got a wooden one
and more than likely you didn't get one
at all okay people didn't care about
time i mean the common folk out in the
streets
they didn't care about the minutes and
seconds it was only for
like you know for maybe astronomers
people who were
the so-called cutting edge of science
those were probably the people who would
be interested in seconds and minutes and
you know kings and princes you know they
they would say hey i'd like to have that
device i can measure
you know time very accurately what for i
don't know
but uh yeah they would be able to do
that okay what happened was you know
they
uh that was again in the 16th century
now you get to the 17th century one of
the first to uh make a
interesting clock would be galileo
and galileo built this uh pendulum clock
well he didn't build i'm sorry he uh he
was blind uh which was a around 1637
1638
and he dictated uh his uh idea to his
son and his son uh made the picture the
drawing that you see on the left there
and it was never built because both of
them galileo and his son died before
they could ever build it and today they
built it and it does work you see it
there on the right
so if they would have built it yet would
have worked okay
and it would have kept time
fairly accurately you know it was uh
perhaps the first at least design
of the pendulum clock
the guy who is really
credited with inventing the
pendulum clock again i don't think he
should be called the inventor maybe
the guy who built the first one but not
the inventor uh was huggins you know
christian higgins he was uh in holland
and he built clocks as well and uh also
you know uh four princes and other rich
folk so he built these clocks and it's a
pendulum clock okay and again uh it was
to
track
time ever more carefully more precisely
okay
and so yeah time was becoming more and
more important not for the ordinary man
because the ordinary man had no use for
seconds
this was only among the rich maybe
only for
interest of some kind
uh it's very likely by that time they
had already calculated you know the um
the fact that a second was so many
uh portions
of the year okay so they they probably
figured that out eventually okay they
did their calculations and were able to
figure out
what portion of a year
first first divided into months then
into weeks days
you know hours and eventually to you
know minutes and eventually two seconds
and they had to have a good idea how
many seconds was in a year okay so they
started
tweaking those numbers they had an idea
and the second now takes
uh a certain importance
at least in the you can call it the
scientific world the world of
researchers okay
okay they started timing things in other
words
okay uh there was an accident that
occurred in 1707 uh
a disaster at sea
and it's uh near the isle of um silly uh
silly island okay and this uh happened
near the
again it's a british
um
military uh contingent that
essentially four of their ships uh fell
as they approached
england and the issue was that these
people miscalculated their position
their location in the sea they thought
they were
where you see the blue dot there
far away from
the
peninsula there that you see okay
penzance and
and
for those of you who know
a little bit of uh
uh united kingdom geography penzance is
that uh peninsula that you see there
right at the corner of that you see that
little island or little sets of island
that's the isle of silly and the issue
was that they thought they were in the
blue dot
when in fact uh they were really at the
d at the red dot and they crashed
against the rocks four of the ships went
down and they lost they don't know
exactly but maybe around 2 000 sailors
okay and they were coming from
gibraltar after a war there against the
french for the succession of the spanish
crown
those kinds of things so what happened
was parliament um
you know they put out a little contest
and they said look little prize they
said we're going to give 3 million bucks
today's 3 million bucks just to give you
an idea
anyone who can figure out longitude
because latitude they can figure out no
problem
but longitude was the issue see latitude
you can figure out uh by using the stars
and the sun and all that stuff so you
can more or less guide yourself in
during the day and at night
but when you have uh longitude you know
uh east-west direction now now what do
you do
and there were a couple problems with
that one was that you know this this
accident this disaster another one was
that um
the way the ships would go in those days
you know people think well they just
sailed out
from europe and went to america for
example right and straight line
and it didn't work that way the way they
did it they would go
north first
following the sun following the stars
right until they reached a region which
they already had mapped
and then they would go straight across
okay
and part of the problem with that was
that the pirates also knew that
they knew the routes
so if you wonder why so many uh
civs
fishy spanish ships why they were
aborted and their loot was
taken away etc was because the pirates
knew the routes and so this was another
problem they wanted to get away from you
know scheduled routes so that they could
go any way they wanted and for that they
needed longitude and so they they put
out this little contest this prize money
and one fellow uh he came out and he
figured out a clock he was a watchmaker
a clockmaker and john harrison was his
name
and he came on and he says okay look he
came up with this little device okay
and
they would take it on ships and they
would know
more or less the
uh
the longitude
and again all this measured time to a
very at very accurate uh
very precise
uh level
and
uh he eventually got his prize money had
to fight for it uh looks like parliament
didn't want to pay him and it took him
some years to get his money but he got
his prize money but because of that you
know they this was a great invention uh
regarding time because now not only
could you
measure time precisely on a ship
you know that's moving around and so on
but on top of that uh
you were able to um
uh
you know use it
to
go to through different routes you
didn't have to take the route that you
always took right
and and because you were able to know
how far away you were from this place or
this other place you would know if you
were going to crash against like
the craggy rocks of uh
of
this little island there okay the silly
island in fact uh if if you never
crashed against the silly island you
were not
not a sailor not a captain of a ship
because just about if you look up the
silly island
there's been a crash almost every year
for the last 300 years you know
everybody's crashed against this island
okay um so what's the story the story is
that you know the year is what was used
all the way at least until the 19th
century in fact throughout the 20th
century all the way to 1967 actually uh
to measure the second okay actually it
was they measured the year and they
divided it up in all these little pieces
12 months 52 weeks et cetera et cetera
and you have 31 million 540
uh 31
a billion 540 million
seconds that's how much we have in a
year
and what is a year 30 kilometers okay
what is bill gates uh definition of time
a comparison of two motions you're
comparing one second that's
your
second hand okay
the second uh division of the hour right
moving one tick mark from one mark to
another that's we'll call that one
second right so it moves one second
during that time
as you say right what are we doing we're
comparing that distance that the
uh
hand went from this distance to this
distance from one tick mark to the other
tick mark
and during that
period the earth went around the sun 30
kilometers so you're comparing two
motions you're comparing the motion of
the second hand on your watch
to 30 kilometers of the motion of the
earth around the sun
that's what a second is that's what time
is time is a comparison of two motions
no one ever figured it out no one ever
had a definition for time i'm giving you
the definition of time okay comparison
of two motions that's all time is
okay but uh did it stay that way
well the 19th century came around and it
was an
unfortunate century especially second
half because the mathematicians started
getting more abstract weirder okay
crazier
they started inventing things that uh
kept them farther and farther away from
physics itself okay and they started
doing a lot of abstract math and
forgetting about physics which is the
opposite of abstract they're antonyms
abstract physics they're opposites so if
you're doing abstractions you're not
doing physic you're farther away from
physics okay and that's what we have
today abstractions
okay so what what was the issue
here i showed the other day okay
where uh they figured out that uh time
dilated okay in other words they say
that if a train goes by a station we
have a difference in
views of the observer that's you know
that's on the platform there
and a passenger on the train and if you
have lightning strike the front and the
back of the train at the same time
exactly at the same time
these two observers are going to see
something different okay one guy the guy
on the on the platform he's going to see
the bottom strike at the same time
because those two rays are going to come
directly at him uh because he's
equidistant from both of them on the
other hand the passenger on the train is
moving in the direction of where the
front of the train is so that that ray
from the front side of the train is
going to reach him first before the one
from the back of the train he would
conclude that those two lightning bolts
did not strike at the same time
okay
and so what's happened here is uh now
they're introducing the observer
into physics now we're talking about
opinions what the guy saw
we're having testimony we're having
witnesses
and that's a no-no in science science is
objective not subjective but they
introduced in this way subjectivity why
because they were trying to calculate
you know they're trying to use their
equation to calculate what one person
would see what the other person would
see when they have uh relative motion
and uh one guy accredited with that was
lawrence
uh uh lorenz um
a mathematician of the late uh 19th
century
and he was credited with coming up with
a lawrence
factor and what is that that's that
little equation that you see at the top
there
and this is how he's going to explain
again this time dilation
and they were trying to figure this out
partly because of
the null or you could say the majority
of mathematicians agreed that there was
a null uh result from the uh
michelson-morley experiment in other
words what michael said morning
apparently did in
1987 is prove to the mathematical crowd
that um
you know that there is no ether
and so they were trying to address that
issue and they ended up with this
equation but this equation is um
you know the the the guy who's credited
with that is
einstein today he's credited with all
this time dilation stuff turns out that
you know
uh lawrence came
uh up with this equation before einstein
did
and even before lawrence we have this
other fellow and uh
his name is voigt he's a german
fellow
and here's this paper you wrote it in
1887
when einstein was only what
eight years old you know einstein was
using his knickers still
and uh and this guy wrote this paper in
which he's got the main factor which is
the one minus v squared over c squared v
squared meaning the velocity your
velocity you're the traveler or whoever
right and c
c squared being the velocity of light
squared and of course if v squared
approaches c squared
v
b squared over c squared equals one one
minus one is zero and you have division
by zero which is not allowed okay it
gives you infinity so uh
you know so they concluded that yeah um
james maxwell was right you can't travel
faster than the speed of light
essentially right and
this was the equation i think the main
component of the
lorentz factor
and it came from this guy boy and it
came when einstein was only eight years
old but einstein's credited with all
this stuff now i don't care about all
this really because you know this is
just math we don't do math and science
we don't do math in physics
it's the mathematicians who incorporate
math into physics and into science math
only describes
science physics explains and that's the
difference between science and math math
is just a language that's all it is it's
a language of descriptions exclusively
doesn't do anything other than describe
science physics is about explaining you
have to explain
what causes gravity
what causes why does a magnet attract
another
this is what you need to explain and so
math helps us
not at all
in that regard you know for that purpose
okay so i don't care much about that who
who was the first i'm just trying to
clarify that einstein was not the
inventor of uh
dilation of any kind you know
mass dilation time dilation length
contraction or dilation or whatever none
of that and then i already was there
when einstein was still a kid
okay so all i'm saying you know we don't
agree with dilation of any kind that
uh
you know that mass contracts
for example
uh you know or math expands or anything
like our length contracts or length to
explain we don't believe in any of that
nonsense because you have to be
irrational to say that because a ruler
traveled at the speed of light it
contracted and then when it stops it
gets bigger again
now that's got nothing to do with a
ruler it's got to do with the observer
and what the observer measures which is
what uh the lawrence factor talks about
it has nothing to do with the ruler
itself it has to do with people
with opinions with witnesses with what
they saw what they measured
and so you have this debate on whether
the contraction is real or not
out there and again it's got to do with
this contraction with with this
factor that they use to decide
mathematically whether something
contracted or not but all that is
observer related it has to do with
measurement
what someone measures an observer
measures
it has nothing to do with the reality of
the thing itself
and that's very easily
shown that it's nonsense with general
relativity really in this case special
relativity what special relativity
proposes and that is that you know the
ruler contracts
well uh so did it becomes shorter
and then suddenly when it arrives at
your desk it grows back again
and you might even say yeah that's the
case okay we'll let it go by how about
mass
mass increase right they say that if you
travel close to the speed of light mass
increases okay you got it right
what is mass quantity of matter
so did we put more atoms that the thing
accumulate more atoms because it travels
close to the speed of light
so the ant turns into an elephant
because it travels at the speed of light
it accumulated all these new atoms
somehow it increased the number of atoms
in its body became an elephant
and then when it comes to rust it goes
back to being an ant
you know again this has to do with the
observer has nothing at all to do with
reality of physics
physical reality okay so the nonsense
that general relativity proposed special
relativity proposes in this instance can
be
you know thrown down to the toilet very
easily it's just poppycock uh it has
nothing to do with physics okay it has
to do with observers and measurement
which is what the mathematicians are
interested in
who only described with equations and
which none of that has anything to do
with explaining
you know how gravity works or how uh you
know magnets work or whatever
okay so what happened well as a result
of this uh einstein was credited with
all this stuff and uh he began
you know stretching the second okay so
he's saying that now we can stretch and
shrink uh seconds depending on you know
how fast you travel
you know so this is what we have today
nothing has changed in the last hundred
years that was
uh what is it 1915 he wrote his
general relativity before that in 1908
the this notion was around already
what is known as relativity or special
relativity
and you had people
other than einstein who already had
come up with this stuff
somehow they gave the credit to einstein
okay
and so yeah we have expanding seconds
now the second stretches okay you can
stretch the seconds why because you
travel at the speed of light or whatever
and also because of location okay and so
one of the things that the
mathematicians do today they said this
has been proven
we've proven it
okay what have you proven well we've
proven that you know if you take
uh a clock
into outer space
it takes at a different rate
antics here on the ground
so
einstein predicted that and so his
theory is correct so he's he's given all
these um
you know pat's in the back he's given
all these kudos
and you know we don't need einstein for
that we knew that uh all along for many
years that you know mercury i'm sorry uh
mars
uh takes about twice as long to go
around the sun than the earth why
because it's farther away from the sun
you know you drill a ball
around your finger the more the longer
you make the string the slower it goes
okay so did we need einstein for that
did we need to run an experiment to
prove that
yeah we already had that idea
but it turns out that einstein is wrong
anyways i mean
his theory is complete bunk
and it's very easily debunked
and i debunk it here very easily okay
and the ideas that they have today is
that if you take a clock and you take it
to outer space okay
that clock should um
run faster
and if you take it down on earth right
at sea level for example it should run
slower why because gravity has an effect
on the clock that's close to sea level
okay
so this clock has the
pull of gravity and goes slower okay and
the clock that's out there because it's
farther away from gravity gravity
doesn't have the same influence over it
it goes faster and they say we've proven
it we've taken clocks out there and
we've proven it
well
maybe just maybe
they didn't take the right clock
i mean if you're going to talk about
time in relation to gravity
you got to take a gravitational clock
not uh atomic clock atomic clocks are
not gravitational clocks they have to do
with the wave
the how many blips you know for example
cesium
wave has
has nothing to do with gravity per se
okay and so what we do is we do it with
a
gravitational clock okay and here's the
most
uh probably the best gravitational clock
that you'll find you can buy it at the
tencent store okay
and it's a known as an hourglass it's
the clock that works exclusively because
of gravity
so that's the best uh clock to test it
with
now you take a cesium clock right
uh
watch a wrist watch you take it out
there and it's gonna distort time
anyways because again if
if if it's at sea level it has a
different rate than if it's out there in
the sky or in this or in space
so we have no accurate clocks if we're
going to talk about accuracy all clocks
dilate
okay so all there's not a clock that
will mark steadily at the same time uh
at different uh regions of space okay
or you know different heights above sea
level or above the center of gravity of
the earth
and so we take our little hourglass and
we show that it's the opposite it's not
that
the clock is faster at uh
you know out there in space it's quite
the opposite it runs slower and if you
take that same clock
a gravitational clock known as an
hourglass right and you take it
to a c level that clock will run faster
because it's closer to
gravity and the grains are going to come
out of the little glass container there
it's going to come out faster
okay so uh
our clock proves general relativity
wrong because it's the it has the
opposite effect of what they predict as
it's known they call it a prediction
well here's a prediction you know i'll
say that my clock runs faster
when it's at sea level than when it's
out there in the middle of nowhere in
fact if you take it farther out
not a single grain will fall and
according to the
lunatics of relativity they would say
that time has stopped because they
decide everything by measurement and now
if not a single grain falls because
there is no gravity out there they say
well time has stopped that's what they
would conclude that's their rationale
that's the way a mathematician thinks he
says oh it goes slower slower slower
and when it goes out there where there's
no gravity they say oh it's stopped
altogether so now time is not longer no
longer flowing slowly now it's stopped
altogether
so that's the mathematical mind how they
think
okay but not only did they stretch the
second
dilated and do all these fancy things
they also chopped it into pieces
they chopped the second they weren't
they weren't satisfied with you know
with
uh just the second okay they had to
because see until the 20th century at
least most of the 20th century uh they
were just dealing with seconds but after
that they invented the millisecond and
the microsecond and the pico second now
we're talking about portions of a second
you know they keep going they're
gonna end up with no second at all
i mean you know they're gonna end up
with zero second and they're gonna say
well what do we call this one the
the uh
second that's approaching zero
almost touching zero i don't know what
they're gonna call it the second is
disappearing folks and that's dangerous
because once it disappeared we have no
time okay
but they invented chronons and what is a
cronon
well this is where you gotta
you know hold on to a seat because you
might fall and break your neck okay the
kronon is a particle
of time
it's like if you take the second
and turn it into a ball
and so now you have a ball of second
the second is a ball okay
what is this uh
chronon well here you have a definition
okay
it goes something like this
it says a cronon is a quantum of time
the smallest discrete and indivisible
unit of time okay so we're talking about
a portion of time okay
a unit of time so far it looks like
they're just talking about numbers right
you say okay take the number line you
chop off the five it's just the number
okay so far so good
uh what's the hypothesis time is not
continuous
well aristotle would have a problem with
that because for
aristotle continues was exactly the
opposite of what they defined there in
other words continues with something
that you could chop
that's what he called continuous
otherwise it was not continuous you
figure that out from good old airy okay
but that's that's the notion he had of
continuity but anyway it says in a
one-dimensional model one-dimensional
model what are they talking about one
dimensional little stick
now they're talking about an itinerary
they call itineraries dimensions in the
religion of mathematics okay so whenever
they say dimension
they're talking about itineraries
they're talking about
especially one dimensional right because
they're talking about an itinerary
traced by whatever object they don't
care about the object they don't care if
it's three-dimensional but they look at
the itineraries it's a one-dimensional
itinerary trajectory or path or whatever
okay so they're saying that
one-dimensional model meaning
a one itinerary model
a cronon is a time interval or period
okay
is a non-decomposable well well in an
n-dimensional model it's a
posable region in in dimensional time
okay
what are they talking about well they're
saying they've got all these little
chronons that form part of this
dimension i thought dimensions were used
to in the context of objects so now
they're saying well we have the length
we're going to chop the length which is
a piece of that object i guess right so
we're talking about a little particle
right and that's exactly what it is it's
a quantum of time okay
but they're saying that time itself
remember time in general relativity at
least is a physical object it's
it's that portion that together with
space forms the
container
in which we
live which we inhabit okay we live in
this container known as space-time
what is uh
gravity well it's the warpage of time
okay you have the earth pushing against
this depression which is time okay
uh time is being warped by the sun
pushing down on the space
time meaning you're warping time and
that's the explanation they give you for
why the earth cannot leave the solar
system because somehow it comes up
against this curved wall of time and so
time is a physical object
and they're going to go in there and
they're going to take a quantum of time
they're going to take a little bit of
that and they're going to say that's the
cronon
so now we have a chronon which is a
little particle of time everything is
particles in
in mathematics they have no never
proposed anything outside of particles
okay what's a particle well who knows
it's certainly not the corpuscle
of old of what is known as classical
physics okay classical mechanics
okay so we have this uh
not only have we stretched
the
second we have chopped it up
and we've converted into a little ball
called the cronon okay
so
so we have all these notions and the
question is you know can you define a
second can you define
time
no you can't define either because they
made a complete mess of it
that's why you can't define it anymore
it's beyond rationality now you know if
you chop the second two little pieces
until you get the pickle second and who
knows what else continuing the tarot
second you know and that's on the one
hand and the other you stretch it you
say well but it's traveling at the speed
of light so now it's stretched
okay and uh
or compressed or whatever right and then
and then you have um
then you have it turned into a ball
because now they have the cronon which
is a particle of time a quantum a
chunk
of time what is time time is this thing
that foreign space time which is a
curved wall against which the earth lies
you know as it rolls around as it orbits
the sun so you have this whole mess
and so yeah you can't define time you
can't define the second under those
uh
assumptions or those theories you know
if those are the theories you're going
to subscribe to how are you going to
define time now how are you going to
find a second well yeah they have no
idea
so what they do is they define
the second you know longer no longer
it's a piece of the orbit of the earth
31
billion 540 i think it was
a
million seconds no it's no longer that
now and that would have been quite
accurate but now they have
this
this atomic clock that measures
you know the the second they look at the
how many
vibrations the cesium wave has and they
call that a second
so many trillion vibrations they say
that's a second
but you take that clock into outer space
and you have a totally different reading
see that doesn't happen with the earth
the earth is constantly going around the
sun more or less at the same rate
but the cesium clock you know if you
take it out of a certain sea level out
of a certain temperature
at a certain distance from gravity you
know etc
all bets are off then you have a totally
different reading in fact someone
calculated i was looking at a
calculation there that fellow says that
if you take the
atomic clock the cesium clock right
and you put that same clock uh on the
moon on the surface of the moon
it would uh be different than one on
earth by 21 seconds i think it was per
hour that guy calculated or something
like that so it would be off by 21
seconds
and so you know it's an inaccurate clock
because it depends
on where it's at in the universe
and so that's not an accurate clock i
think a much more accurate clock is the
earth going around the sun which is
quite reliable you know at least so far
until an asteroid hits us or whatever
causes our extinction right
okay um so this is what the
they have today this is the
uh we've replaced the
orbit of the earth around the sun with
this
contraption there they made more uh
user-friendly contraption since this was
probably one of the first ones that
looked like that it was a big thing
today they have it made smaller
but they have these atomic clocks they
put them on the satellites and they
control gps okay
uh by trilateration okay
okay so uh um
what's what's the deal well here's
here's the conclusion of all this so
that see we can
recap uh what the second is what time is
okay
and these are my conclusion relativity
is based on space time that means time
is very important very important leg
of
general relativity which is the
you know the current catechism
in mathematical physics so-called called
also physics erroneously called physics
also called science again erroneously
called science none of this has anything
to do with science whatsoever
uh because science explains and these
guys they describe with equations which
could be correct we don't care about
that but then the explanation they give
is
totally irrational and that's what we
look at we look at what's your mechanism
for gravity what's your mechanism for
[Music]
attraction of two magnets what is your
mechanism for electricity in the
workings of the atom that's what we're
interested in and you will never get it
from
mathematical physics in general and
relatively in particular okay
no definition of time today we have none
today maybe next time
yeah we have no definition of the word
time and these are some of the
definitions you'll find out there i just
put three out there but you'll find more
similar to these what are clock measures
or reads
okay what's a clock
well a clock is what measures or reads
time
so we don't know what uh what it's
measuring you know
what do you mean what a clock measures
you know measuring a horse while it runs
i mean we don't know what a clock
measures
okay the continued sequence of existence
and events
the continued sequence one thing right
after another
well that could be locations one
location after another in uh you know uh
something that's moving is that time
okay we have uh
one um
like you take uh a movie right you look
at the frames of the movie
and here you have the horse in one
location another location another
location no another location well you
have the sequence of existence
is that time
if that's all that god made out there
you know just uh you know a horse at
different locations
is that time or is that just motion
so no uh that definition is obviously
wrong
a measure of of nonstop
measure of non-stop
uh consistent change
of non-stop consistent change
again you know if something changes
is that time or is that just motion
the word change is a synonym of motion
not of time
for time you need memory
you need to memorize the locations of
the two objects which you are comparing
that are moving and whose motions you
are comparing that's what time is and so
you need memory without memory you have
no time okay so that's very important
anyways the second is only 400 years old
it's not 2
500 years old as you'll see throughout
the internet all these people are just
parenting what other people saying just
put it in there say oh the 60 seconds
came from the
assyrians or the sumerians or whatever
no the 60 the
60 system came from them not the second
or the minute that came only about 400
years ago okay so
that's a new invention it's uh still in
its infancy you could say
and it's already about to die uh i guess
uh what i call it uh when
they uh grow old very suddenly those
babies uh can't remember the name of the
disease
anyways uh yeah this is a baby that's
already grown very old very suddenly
[Music]
the second has been stretching
partitioned so you know if you stretch
it
you still have a second
if you cut into pieces do you have a
second
if you turn it into a ball
do you have a second i mean
we've lost all track of what a second is
right now and they say well we measure
it with the cesium wave you know
vibrations
but you take that out into outer space
it has a different reading so
what's a second we have no idea we don't
have a definition for it
and we don't know what it is because
again you know if they say it's the so
many vibrations the cesium well you take
it out there it has a different reading
that means you have to specify more
conditions meaning
at what latitude what temperature et
cetera et cetera
and so you know it's very very pretty
you know you got to be very precise on
on what you mean by the second today and
you can't really define it except with
putting so many of these parameters in
there okay once you take it a little bit
further higher farther lower
all bets are off
okay uh they morphed it into a particle
the famous cronon is now the
new particle of time
and it's interesting that it forms uh
part of space-time because if the cronon
is for real if if that quantum of time
is going to form
part of space time
it forms part of the canvas
okay
and if it forms part of the canvas
because it prevents the earth from
flying out of the solar system
well then you're talking about a real
physical entity we're not talking about
an abstraction anymore now we're talking
about a ball
these people are saying that you know
this uh
this phone on uh
i'm sorry it is cronon
uh is part of spacetime and because it's
part of this uh canvas the
fishnet right maybe
where the fish net where the little
strings of the fishnet cross maybe those
are the
uh cronons right
because it's it's a little ball that
forms part of the fish then we're
talking about a real object you cannot
later on wish it away and say well we
were you don't you're not supposed to
take it literally you're not supposed to
take the analogy literally no no what
they're describing is a physical object
they're saying though cronin is a ball a
ball this ball is part of space time it
forms one second or maybe a millisecond
maybe a micro second
or a tera second you know who knows what
but it forms a part of a physical object
that prevents the earth from flying out
of the solar system
how am i supposed to interpret that as
an abstraction the earth is for real
and so if something is holding it
in its orbit
around the sun
what is it what physical entity is it
and these people are saying it's space
time what is space time made out of made
out of chromos
okay
let's uh move on to some of the
questions and comments people made
says because the time and space are
concepts okay because time and space are
concepts okay
there is no need for a rope to connect
two atoms
okay i don't know where you got that
from or what his line of reasoning is if
you can call it reasoning the rope would
therefore have to be what a concept as
well as existing within the concept of
space and time
a concept that exists
you see what happens when people don't
define the terms
so so these this fellow is talking about
an existing concept a concept that
exists
no such monster in science okay concepts
do not exist in science objects can only
be said to exist
and so this is one of the problems that
you have when people don't define their
terms the fellow continues the only
logical conclusion logical he thinks
he's logical he thinks he's rational
is that in the present there is no
separation between matter and all matter
is one
he's saying there is no separation of
matter this is his logical conclusion
and all matter is one and there you have
it the block universe or the cubic
universe or whatever
separation can only exist
with concepts of time and space
so he's going to use time and space to
divide but he says the only conclusion
is that there is no separation
he went around in circles like 10 times
there
so the question to him is if there is no
separation
okay between matter and that all matter
is actually one he's talking about a
something that's made out of a single
piece
talking about an object that is made out
of single piece in this case a cube
and the question is what are all those
galaxies and stars and planets
inside that cube
how come they're separate how come i can
distinguish a galaxy from a star a star
from a planet a planet from an asteroid
and so on down the line from a gas
molecule or whatever
i can distinguish them because somehow
they're partitioned or separated from
the next guy over
if they're separated obviously something
is chiseling them apart and we call that
space
and so he can he said the only
technological conclusion is that there
is no separation between matter and all
matter is one
and again it's because people like him
don't define their terms
and they just use terms of ordinary
speech and they bring him into science
indiscriminately they don't even pay
attention they don't even know what they
said
this is the problems that's why when you
come into physic when you come into
science
you have to be very very careful with
definitions and we are very careful here
and people don't like that they say oh
you redefined the term well yeah we
redefine terms we've been redefining
terms for the last two thousand years
you just find out about that we
constantly define terms redefine terms
whenever we see the need to redefine
them and if you have an irrational
definition that is okay in ordinary
speech but you cannot bring it into
science because you cannot use it
consistently
then you have to redefine the term
and the way it works one guy defines the
other guy doesn't like it because it
destroys his religion
okay he's got a single uh recourse and
that is to
bring a definition that he can defend he
gets inside the ring with sword and
shield and defends his definition
and it doesn't work like a lot of people
like to do they say well that's the way
we've always used it
or
all the mathematicians voted for it
well i don't care if they all voted for
the flat earth you know mother nature
doesn't care about that so we don't care
if all mathematicians
voted for a
theory or for a definition for a
mechanism if it's irrational and mother
nature doesn't approve of it okay so it
doesn't matter if all of them vote which
we call democracy it doesn't matter if
they get it from a book that's been
around for 100 years we don't care about
tradition
or you know any other argument of that
nature
no you there's only one way and that is
for you to come up with a definition and
be able to defend it
from any attack that people raise
against
then you have a solid definition okay
that's how it works in science
okay here um another file says
time is change or the interval of change
okay
uh
changes motion
motion is not time
they're not
identical
you have to have two motions comparing
two motions in order to have time you
can have change in motion
and not necessarily have yet
time okay
and it says or the interval change
against
irrelevant uh
[Music]
change is not a synonym of time change
is a synonym of motion you need two
changes two motions in order to have
time you need memory also
okay unsigned general theory of
relativity established time as a
physical thing he's absolutely right
there okay he said time is a physical
thing that's what einstein essentially
uh determined okay he turned it into a
solid
okay so to speak maybe it's a fluid
maybe bendable a little bit you know
maybe not completely solid but yeah he
turned it into a thing
it is part of space-time he's totally
right there the gravitational field
warps space-time
okay we got
on the one hand he said it right that's
what
uh mathematical physics says that's what
um general relativity says
but then uh we have a problem with the
word field because field is not a
physical object you cannot say that the
concept
let's say the concept love
warps the concept intelligence
or vice versa intelligence warping love
uh what sense does that make and that's
what you're saying when you say that a
field which is a concept
warps time which is concept
okay or space-time which is another
concept so you cannot say because if you
look up the word field says a value at
each location around an object that's
what a field is so we have a bunch of
numbers a bunch of values
you know numbers and units
and what general relativity says is that
uh these numbers
warp
a physical object which is not one but
they treat it as a physical object which
is space type
so yeah we have a problem here because
the physical interpretation of this is
nonsense it's poppycock that's no
place in science okay
time can appear to move faster or slower
whoa
yeah when i have 10 beers time goes very
fast or slow
drives me nuts you know so i try not to
drink too much because otherwise time
flows faster or beyond me and i can't
catch up with it yeah time is not a
physical object but if you treat it as a
physical object then you talk about it
moving slow or fast if time is a concept
you can't talk about it moving at all
let alone fast or slow
time passes yeah it just passed me by
very fast
time passes more slowly close to a
massive body
uh but see uh with the
with the
uh
hourglass it's the other way around uh
so this is
nonsense from general relativity no time
goes faster
uh close to gravity
you can prove it to yourself
take a
an hour glass
you could take a water clock you know
clutch syndra
and uh and just put it there and then
take it into outer space or somewhere
very far maybe to a mountain
high above sea level
and that one should go slower than the
guy that's close to the sea level
so uh einstein's wrong i don't know
where einstein got this nonsense that
all clocks
you know runs uh slower or faster at
different heights he's got in reverse
you know for some clocks at least okay
time dilation isn't just theoretical
whoa okay so uh yeah what do you mean
not theoretical if it's not theoretical
what is it you mean like what and it
says and our and i put that at the
the pub
is equivalent to seven years in space
that i believe
i i
i give faith yeah yeah when you're at
the pub for one hour it's like seven
years in space
yeah some of these folks and they
believe all this stuff you know a lot of
them
um they cannot explain it but
they believe in it okay
here we have another phone i think uh
what is time someone asked
i asked that in fact i said what is time
that was the previous
lecture paul says a concept correct
that's all it is just a concept another
fellow answers him says concept an
abstract idea a general notion
he got this from the dictionary
apparently because obviously it's
nonsense what he what he put there
and he says to the first guy he says are
you sure that you want
stick with saying time is only a thought
in the mind an abstract idea
and you look up idea it says any
conception
concept okay a thought conception or
notion
what is notion conception or idea so all
we have so far are synonyms
none of what this felt but are
definitions that we can use in science
because they're all circular definitions
known as a synonym antonyms are also
circular definitions you can't say dog
is not a
horse uh yeah no kid
it's not a whale not a bird you know so
so we don't use antonyms we don't use
synonyms to define words scientifically
okay uh another
comment
can you quote uh one of these scientists
who say particles come out of nothing
please
well uh one fellow brian cox he's a
pretty
famous guy he's got some his name and
lights out there and you can look him up
he's british right um bran cox says that
they come from the fourth dimension
these uh gravitons so they come from the
fourth dimension so that's
i mean
saying that it comes from the fourth
dimension is putting outside beyond your
reach
so you're going to say well how can i
find what can i how can i
verify that or whether it's in the
fourth dimension you can't get to it
and so that's a good way of putting it
beyond your reach it's like saying well
what about god well god is beyond your
reach well how can i reach god i want to
see him touch him and they said you you
must pray and believe and have faith
and this is more or less the same thing
it comes from the fourth dimension
but okay so that's one answer but the
majority say it comes from the vacuum
and you can look up larry krauss another
popular guy
and he's got a
book and
he's got also a couple youtube videos a
universe from
nothing
okay so particles come out of nothing
forget about particles an entire
universe they say comes out of nothing
and
i think i have here
no
anyways the deal is that you know
lots of people talk about universes
coming out of nothing and particles
coming out of nothing in fact all of
quantum mechanics talks about uh you
know particles appearing from the void
that they ran all kinds of experiments
and you don't have to ask me just look
it up on the internet i mean all you'll
find is that so
to ask me to come up with an example
like saying
can you find at least one example hey
go on the internet put the question
there you'll find millions of examples
where everyone in quantum mechanics says
that particles appear from the void they
pop in from the void okay and among them
i've talked about all this in the past
but
you have the direct c you know particles
uh that appear from nothingness in other
words saying that the vacuum itself
known as the ether right is uh built of
negative and positive
particles you know that's that's what he
came up with and that's what we have
today we have these virtual particles
what are virtual particles well virtual
particles are particles that appear out
of nothing
so look up the virtual particle and
you'll find out you don't have to ask me
this question because uh it's not that
like i invented or i'm
coming up with something you know out of
nowhere
you just look it up on the internet and
you'll find out that particles come out
of nowhere everywhere in quantum
mechanics that's a done deal
and what are particles well they're wave
functions so
so that's another issue
okay falsetto the antidote for
christianity is literacy
yeah i i kind of agree with him you know
um but you know some people are literate
in the sense that they know how to read
so you would have to really define what
literacy is okay
some people are well educated in fact
there was one british fellow that
was interviewed he was a physicist
and he believes in god and i'm sure
there's many of them out there
mathematical physicists who vouch for
god who believe in god maybe they have
their own god a different way than what
is known out there
but yeah they uh they're you can say
they're literate
and they still believe in god so i don't
think that literacy unless you define
literacy very well
i'm not sure you can say that um
literacy is what determines christianity
okay you have people who are literate in
many ways and they still believe in god
or use god as a
as a foundation for physics in their
minds okay
okay uh says a scientific explanation
theory right is the presentation of
objects and movements of those objects a
mechanism
that the presenter posits could have
resulted in the set of observed
phenomena for which an explanation is
and yeah that's a
pretty good summary uh we subscribe to
this notion of what science is it's just
uh explanation
rational explanation if it's irrational
it's not an explanation at all
and that's what a theory is an
explanation so yeah i pretty much
subscribe to what this fellow said
at least that's what we
push for in this channel okay so yeah
100 points there from ours to you right
and final issue phil says black hole the
term black holes alone should raise
doubts because a hole is by definition
not black
and if it is a hole what can be seen
behind it because you're looking at a
hole you got to see something behind it
that's what he says right
nothing because a hole is just a round
or square border of an object but is the
but is the universe an object because
you should be able to see the universe
right through the hole but he's saying
what do you see well you see nothing
because
there is no hole okay
the universe must be an object right
because if you see something through the
hole then the universe has to be an
object it has to be a thing right
because that is exactly what is
indirectly claimed if you
think through black hole properly yeah
if you can see like there you have the
famous black hole that they say they
proved okay
which is not a black hole
uh
they qualify that and they say well it's
not actually a black hole is
matter
rushing into a black hole and it creates
this image which they took with many
uh
from many regions took many shots as a
composite right they built this so you
have to understand what this image
really represents and what it is is
according to them okay it's just matter
falling into a black hole what you're
looking at is
uh
the drain in your sink
okay you turn on the faucet right the
water rushes out it twirls around okay
that's what you're seeing here the
trolley around
and it falls inside the drain which is
the black hole okay that's the analogy
okay but
what you're seeing there is not the
black hole not the drain you're not
seeing the drain what you're seeing
there the whole thing that you're seeing
there is just
all this um
water
swirling around
falling into a black hole which is
zero dimensional there's nothing there
black hole is zero dimensional
there is no length width or height in a
singularity
and you say bell you're inventing all
this stuff where did you get this
nonsense blah blah blah
don't take my word for it okay
go and find out what uh chandrasekhar
won his nobel prize for
he wanted for proving
that a black hole
star right collapses to zero d
zero dimensions he won the nobel prize
for proving
that a star can collapse to zero size
you hearing me listening to me
he won that nobel prize for that and if
you don't want to look that up you can
look up
um
stephen hawking's book
a brief history of time
okay
where i think 1987
and in his book
he tells you that chandrasekhar proved
that a black hole
singularity right is zero dimensional
there's nothing uh there you can't peep
through that hole because it's so small
that it's nothing
you're looking at space itself
that's what chandrasekhar won his nobel
prize for a lot of people have problems
saying no no bill it's not zero
dimension it's approaching
uh no size
no no no there's no reason for it to
approach no size it goes all the way and
becomes no size
and the funny part about that is that
you know it crushes all matter out of
existence
if it crushes all matter out of
existence
and mass is the quantity of matter
there is no matter
there is no mass
and so
a black hole is not only zero
dimensional but it's
massless
i'll see you on wednesday